big debate has broken out over whether
Elon Musk should ban the word CIS c-i-s
from Twitter
and it's still raging I mentioned this
on the show a few days ago but it's
still raging and Brad Palumbo my debate
partner from the University of
Pittsburgh and Brad pinch hit after the
transgender identifying Professor that I
was supposed to debate on issues of
gender and sex dropped out at the last
minute because he felt that he couldn't
do the debate so Brad comes in and uh
Brad is a
self-described libertarian and he says
Elon Musk is the worst free speech hero
ever
and uh that's because you should be able
to say anything on Twitter and if you
don't this is absolutely terrible
and of course Brad is wrong here and I
wrote a book about how what Elon is
doing is fabulous the book is called
speechless controlling words controlling
wines number number one National
bestseller thank you very much this is
one of the most encouraging things that
Elon has done because it shows a
sophistication not just a sophomoric
very Elementary vision of politics that
is based on Modern incoherent ideologies
that have never been put into practice
effectively anywhere in the world
throughout all of human history but he's
recognizing that there's Nuance here we
support Free Speech but when we support
Free Speech we're supporting a tradition
not something in the abstract floating
in outer space but a real tradition with
exclusions exclusions like threats like
obscenity like fighting words like fraud
like all of these sorts of things and uh
I'm Elon is a great figure in technology
and business but a lot of guys when they
dip their toes from their areas of
expertise into politics they sometimes
demonstrate a great deal of ignorance
Elon here I think is demonstrating a lot
of sophistication and you see it
actually
in the case of the affirmative action
decision
the whole thing is about standards and
the affirmative action case asks what
kind of standards are we going to have
in this country
and so far what the judges are saying
now is we're going to have something
closer to a meritocracy
and before that on affirmative action
you're gonna have something closer to a
racial hierarchy with black people and
Native Americans and I don't know at the
top of it and then maybe uh Hispanics
they go a little bit lower and then
Asians and white people at the bottom
and if you're a member of a favored race
you get special treatment and if you're
a member of a disfavored race you're the
scum of the earth and and you're going
to be discriminated against that was the
view that predominated for the last
many decades you know four or five
decades maybe six decades now I guess uh
now what happened before that a lot of
conservatives want to be a little
simplistic about this and say well
before affirmative action you just had a
pure meritocracy but that's not quite
true and we don't just have quite a pure
meritocracy now because there are other
factors at play right now go to
cinch.com use promo code Knowles Fourth
of July is upon us with many wonderful
family gatherings popping up the last
thing that you need when hosting your
family is turning on the grill and being
out of propane
that would be terrible that's where our
friends at cinch come in cinch is a
propane grill tank Home Delivery Service
they deliver propane tanks right to your
door on your schedule they do not
require any long-term commitment or
subscription plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to wait
around at home track the order on the
Cinch app from anywhere the perfect
summer night would not be complete
without cinch go online to cinch.com or
download the Cinch app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just 10 bucks with promo
code nulls cinch.com or download the
Cinch app use promo code nulls to get
your first tank exchange for just 10
bucks this is a limited time offer you
must live within a cinch service area to
redeem it visit cinch.com right now
slash offer for details and make sure
that you sign up summer is here baby
it's the fourth of July do not even have
to think about your propane tanks
cinch.com promo code nulls there is
legacy admissions
don't favor the highest test scores they
favor people with a tie to the
university the pure meritocrats say we
need to get rid of legacy admissions but
that's not a conservative point of view
you want some continuity you want people
to say no my family has had a connection
to this institution not just a college
but maybe a church maybe a neighborhood
maybe a community organization maybe
maybe a maybe a senate seat for goodness
sakes you know tradition and continuity
and
uh the kind of experience that you don't
just learn out of a textbook or learn on
your own for the first time but that is
imbued into you and your family from
birth
that's a pretty conservative thing we
like tradition we like we like things
outside of pure rationalistic book
learning
okay there's that there is
the essay
and the college essay is supposed to
figure out how well you think and how
well you write
but that personal statement also says
something about who you are what your
experiences are probably now the people
who do want to discriminate against
white people uh in college admissions
they will just increase the importance
of the personal essay and they will use
that as a way to say okay if the person
indicates that he is not white then
we'll give him a little bit more of an
advantage here
um so that's that's not just a pure
meritocracy and before affirmative
action that that's certainly true there
were inherited privileges uh obviously
there was a different kind of racial
discrimination in the country and all
sorts of other
all sorts of other little prejudices and
all sorts of other little ineffable
complications of life that made things a
little bit different at the founding of
the country uh my friend sirab Amari
pointed this out on Twitter just
yesterday the Jeffersonian ideal which
you might say was a pure meritocracy
wasn't quite a pure meritocracy it was
this idea that you have a lot of Yeoman
Farmers that you'd have a lot of people
who had their own property in their own
land but not Grand Estates just you know
relatively
more modest Republican lowercase R types
of land so there are all these different
views and different
standards and and I think we just need
to be aware of that all the time because
we can fall into the same trap of saying
no the absolutely totally purely
objective neutral standard is
meritocracy now that's not really
totally neutral either that's an
ideology too
the totally absolutely free unregulated
free market that's the neutral thing no
that that's a standard too and some
people might object to that standard so
we need to be a little bit more
forthright about it this is a big step
in the right direction we need to be
even clearer moving forward boy what a
great clip that was now hey make sure
you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel
see you next time